hey everybody and welcome to a
hard-hitting wild ride with stevo we've
got the ultimate legend of mma chuck
liddell the iceman and i'm totally bros
with chuck for years in fact we were
together when i found wendy in the
streets of peru and boy is he going to
serve it up for you on this episode not
just sex drugs and rock and roll but how
about on a 150 foot yacht yeah dudes
strap on your seat belts and enjoy the
ride and speaking of rides i'm on tour
and on my tour bus
man gotta say i've had a lot of problems
not the least of which was with the
crappy mattress that came with that damn
bus but my friends at helix dudes they
hooked me up i reached out i said hey
dudes can you give me a good quality
mattress for my crappy tour bus and they
did man and they can hook you up too
because you had such a rad deal from
them if you go to helix sleep.com
stevo you take an easy two minute quiz
which sets you up with the custom
mattress which is perfect for you and
will give you the best night's sleep you
get
up to 200 off any mattress you choose to
buy and it comes with a 100 day risk
risk-free guarantee where if you don't
like it they'll even come and pick it up
for you but hey man you're gonna love it
and not only get up to 200 off of any
mattress you want plus they give you two
free pillows with it and their pillows
are the best
so one more time go to helix sleep.com
stevo and now let's get into it with the
iceman
ladies and gentlemen chuck liddell
yeah dude
and of course
you know scott randolph and the gorgeous
paul briskey good to see you good to see
you chuck good to see you man yeah
there's not too many people you can have
on your podcast that you can really say
are legends but i'm calling you a legend
oh thank you
do you feel like a legend
i you know i never i never get i don't
know i never it's kind of something
someone else tattles you you know it's
kind of yeah it is kind of cool when my
son looks up and goes dad why why do
people call a new legend yeah
i'll explain that to you someday yeah
you're like let me just pull you up a
youtube video and tell you why yeah what
did your buddy say glooly he said uh if
you're good people will tell you if
you're great no no no
if like uh if you're good odds are
you're telling everybody if you're great
everyone else is saying it for you yeah
that's so cool
that's good have your kids seen like
your fight videos and [ __ ] like you're
already oh they've seen some yeah
now they have yeah
they've seen some stuff are they like
that's you
no they just got they they
they they think it's cool yeah i bet oh
yeah you know they got a little thing
like you know action action figures for
my kids i mean that was one of the cool
things first got first action figure i
got i gotta go kids playing with you
know um sitting he's over there playing
with a chocoladel doll um wow beating up
spiderman or beating up like
something like that that's kind of cool
you know that that doll always wins when
he's playing
yeah dude so uh
man
and
you are with me
and paul briskey
when uh when we found wendy in the
streets of peru oh yeah for sure yeah
you and i were down there uh
doing
mountain climbing with the stars that's
right ultimate expedition yeah yeah you
know i i never i i don't think i even
ever told you you know what you know
what i um i misunderstood when i signed
up for that i misunderstood when it was
oh so
um i i got cleared for my neck surgery
i got cleared to to
do anything besides walk
um like
uh a week after i got back
i was like i'm like
i thought it was a guy somehow for some
reason i thought it started in october
and
then i said uh like the end of july or
whatever or bringing along oh man i had
like two weeks to i just got cleared
before two weeks before i left to hike
like
before that didn't want me hiking they
wanted to fall and hurt my neck yeah you
heard something but like i got cleared
two weeks before i go go then i went
there to go hiking so i i hiked a few
times before i got to get ready for the
show
i haven't done anything for months how
far were you guys hiking during the show
were you guys i mean dude
just to get to base camp was like a
13-hour hike what just yeah to get to
the base camp was
yeah so like to start the show it's like
hey we're going to film the show so we
got to go to our base camp that's a
13-hour hike for everybody and there's
no way to not watch it
without ends at 14 000
feet that's 14 000 feet yeah your base
camp was at 14 000 feet yeah yeah i
think so was that when you were huffing
the blow up thing and then you like got
all you're dizzy uh-huh that's 14 000
feet yeah i mean we were uh at altitude
it was gnarly yeah
like that
was the i remember you having a tough
time like you got sick and i i never got
sick but i i i did pass out after
going up the uh
that that second last hike i i
came back i went to go i went to take my
backpack off and just felt fell off i
just fell on my oh my god i thought woke
up looking up the star going oh
maybe it was a good idea to go back down
why because going down well they know
the guy um uh well he's just like you're
not going to make it you know like i was
coming up we kept going i was like i'm
good i'm fine i'm fine you know you're
going too slow we're not going to make
it like you're not going to make it up
there and the big problem is once we get
up there i don't know if we get you down
we're going to have to get you down so
he said you're not going to make it what
because it was checking out oxygen
i was just not i was just struggling
that bad right right right like you're
just like i just couldn't i just kept
going back i got no i'm fine i go i got
keep going but he's like we gotta just
pick it up we gotta keep going faster i
remember thinking dude chuck's not okay
yeah and then i went back but but you
know i went back down i sat down and i
woke up i i thought i was walking
through a field and i look up and i'm
like
oh
oh wait okay i know where i'm at wow i
guess i'm down here
i just passed out they knew you passed
out or you passed out just on your own
like do you know
they actually they they they saw me come
back come back now like he took cameras
off me and then they'll leave me alone
because i got my sit there like
you know and then i took my i took my
bag off as soon as i took my bag off i
set it down and i went wow and that was
for the the the final
the sec the second the second last the
second and the last one
right
that was the more mellow one and then
what was the one that looked like
titties
titty
for the people that don't know what
you're talking about what show are you
going to show his ultimate expedition
for youtube red it was a bunch of
celebrities and youtubers
and the goal is just it's like a
mountain climbing show with the stars
it's just like steve explains why they
train us how to do stuff yeah and have
it have us hike up and the basic goal is
just to get somewhere into the summit
and it's it's it's a tough thing anyway
because because the altitude is hard on
on
people are affected in different ways by
altitude i don't think it did much to me
like uh
and and some it's just crazy dude it's
kind of like maybe like covet affects
some people a lot and other people you
guys were in peru were you doing were
people eating cocoa leaves to for the
alcohol oh yeah that was a thing they
had a giant like bag of it like fierce
pee and like but like a giant
pillow case bag of it oh yeah i was
chewing it the whole time yeah that that
that uh didn't sound like a good idea
for me to do yeah me neither i don't
think i would yeah i remember we first
got there you were like checking into
the hotel and you're like hmm like they
just offered me a cocaine tea
like uh i don't think i could do that
and what does it what did you feel like
after you were chewing on it just a
little like buzzy i mean i've never done
coke but it was like you've actually
never done coke never done coke what a
sweet kid
chuck liddell's done coke
but you were never like uh
that was never like what you were all
about right that was no
no it happened here in the irish house
but no no it was the early 2000s right
yeah yeah you ever uh
never do coke off of a woman's butt
it's a serious question
oh man
wendy's out of here
wendy's like i'm just going to ruin
those cameras over there yeah um so dude
um
you were also you probably don't hear
about this so
much but you were a part of big brother
magazine
oh yeah and uh
that was a that was fun that was funny
that was a that was a funny skit right
and the skit was that like you beat up
the their intern their internet turned
steve
and their intern steve is scott's
brother oh no way yeah that's my brother
oh yeah so that that whole thing was so
funny like at the end that you know at
first i like they didn't want gloves
they didn't want to have like we're
gonna put some gloves on if we're gonna
spar i'm not gonna accidentally hit this
guy and split them open
um we're going and i'm i'm moving around
with the kid and i'm i hit with a jab
and i mean he almost falls down like i'm
like okay i don't wanna you know gotta
be careful not hitting too hard
and i'm messing around and they're like
you know be really cool this last round
if you just knocked them out
i'm like
dude
i can't do that
i mean
it's because it's you're in a bad
position right like so i'm a
professional fighter known for power and
you're asking me to knock this kid out
so no
i've got to hit him
and if i get him to try to knock him out
i got to hit him as hard as i can
because you don't know how good a punch
a guy can take a guy some guys you can
hit him up with a well you tap and they
fall over the other guys you have the
brick and they're still coming so
if i'm gonna knock this guy if i say i'm
gonna knock this guy out i gotta go
there and hit him hard
i'm gonna go so i'm like this guy's an
intern he's he was talking about me
before this is a
he was worried about he was worried
about it like me hurting him the whole
time because we were talking earlier so
i'm like oh my god you're gonna be fine
we'll get through this and uh i'm like
dude no no sorry i mean one thing if one
of these guys asked me dude like you
know that you you're making money you're
doing stuff that's not but there's no
there's no way i'm gonna knock out some
kid well you were knocking them down by
leg kicks yeah they asked me knocking
about leg kicks i i can i can do that
because
those heal they don't honestly i i i
think they don't feel very good i
remember
but they had to get out yeah i could do
that i could knock him down legit so
he'll fall
okay i can't kick my leg he'll fall i
remember that morning when he was going
to go do it he was in the kitchen eating
vicodin because he wanted to like get
numb before he went in and then uh
there's i can think of why he was eating
bikini because he was a heroine yeah
he had a problem like the day before too
no but then when he's breakfast
when he when he got home i remember he
was telling me about the the whole
experience and how he was like uh he was
like yeah he kicked the [ __ ] out of me
and i was like were you going as hard as
you you know was i asked him if he was
going as hard as he can on he was like i
was going 110 as i could and i said was
he going 100 on you he's like he was
going like 10 and he was [ __ ]
killing me
[Music]
i mean like once like steve your brother
stephen randolph is not a fighter like
what's 100
no
like but that's the thing and that's the
difference with people like in high
school or college like they get in bar
fights and they think they can fight but
like going up against a professional oh
it's like night and day it's a total
different thing like i mean i you know
guys like i see guys like oh i got
jumped by four dudes i'm looking at them
like
where'd they hit you like you got you
don't have any marks like how did you
get jumped like
yeah how are you in a fight with four
dudes and you had no marks before my
buddies beat you up you being bobby
you look like a pinata right yeah
yeah i just remember that back in the
day like when when ufc started taking
off it's like some of the guys were like
i mean dude you know so-and-so would do
pretty well against one of these guys
and it's like there's not a chance in
hell
any of these guys on the street can come
close to like kicking
the [ __ ] out of a professional fighter
oh yeah there's a lot of i mean
back in the day especially like you can
hear people talking about and i get
there like here because i know the guy
was fighting all that guy's a [ __ ]
get into this i'm like
really you want to fight him i'll fly
him out here i really no really i'll fly
him out here you beat him i'll give you
a thousand bucks
you know i never no one took me up on it
yeah i bet i know like i'm like do that
right because my buddy just lost but he
and he's and you're saying that like
that you couldn't even hold this jock
strap like hit it
like he's not gonna it's like i'll be
happy i'm happy to fly him out here and
beat your ass for saying that
would uh would people try and fight you
like when you were like out drinking or
something with some macho guy trying to
i really never had that problem i mean i
i think i think for me one of the big
things uh you know a lot of times guys
won't want to fight like like
celebrities or people that are in sports
even boxers or whatever they're like oh
he's he's a boxer not a street fighter
he's a wrestler not a street fighter
just like i was known as like a street
brother with heavy hands right so i
wasn't really the guy you want to do
that with and the other thing well yeah
a lot of you always think i'm a lot
bigger than i thought i was going to be
so i'm bigger than i thought and then
the other one is um
though the thing is that most [ __ ]
that would do that were fans of it so
yeah right that was one of their
favorite fighters so as long as i i'm so
laid back like if you if that come up
i'm always nice to the people right i
give i wouldn't give him a reason to
start a fight with me yeah i mean you
really got you i mean i i just tell
people i told you all the time if if you
talk your way into a fight with me
um you're good because i mean your your
mom
your mom's gonna ask me why i waited so
long to be trashed yeah that's that's
how my biggest [ __ ] you are yeah
certainly that's epic
and before you were a fighter you were a
bouncer
yeah i bounced on that bartender most of
the time but i was uh i broke up most
fights too in the bar but
i was a little it was a little easier
from behind the bar actually because you
could see people you could see it
happening bill you hitting it before it
starts see you guys
throw ice at him you know i just throw
ice at him hey is that how you get the
name dice man
it's not gonna be funny why would the
lights happen
hey you go that way you go that way
leave each other alone that's funny
though i picture you bartending
security's like uh chuck can you help us
please
my buddy chris pontius told me to ask
you about uh like
fighting with like a bunch of navy seals
safe to say it takes some serious balls
to fight a bunch of navy seals and how
are you gonna do that if you got no
[ __ ] balls well good news is this
month the month of april is testicular
cancer awareness month and my good
friends from manscaped are getting
behind the cause by supporting their
longtime partner the testicular cancer
society by releasing this special
edition lawnmower 4.0 there are only 10
000 of these purple tcs special edition
lawnmowers in existence and if you buy
them one then you're getting behind this
great cause and contributing to the
fifty thousand dollars manscape is
donating to it yeah so
even better than that is the deal you
get if you use the promo code stevo at
manscape.com then you're gonna get 20
off your order plus free shipping for
getting behind this epic cause and not
to mention having good looking nice
groomed balls which you need to be
checking on to make sure that they don't
have cancer okay thank you manscape for
being such good wonderful people and
thank you for going to
manscaped.com and using the promo code
stevo now let's talk about fighting navy
seals
yeah that happened a long time people
ask that all the time um
i mean it was i for me i wasn't involved
in most of it uh the first time they
came in
most of all of us were all the guys like
that that trained with me that that
normally working at that bar were in
hawaii with us like because we all went
to hawaii for our
our whole fight team went
and gained mcgee was still there
who's 6 10 uh
almost 300 pounds and he fought for ufc
world title at one point but he he was
involved in it he got he got caught i
cut over his eye i got to cut somewhere
on his face i think and then a couple of
buddies really pissed off and everyone's
mad about it and then
they showed up again two weeks later and
and so the guys kind of
go got got back at him um i when i
showed up they had one of my buddies had
a guy panda the only thing i did was i i
ran over hey and this guy's was hitting
my buddy when he had the guy the guy
started hitting everybody who had him
pinned i ran over to snap head snapped
the guy bounced his face off the ground
uh so he got his head
what is it i just grabbed his head
grabbed his head and just
just
moved back and pulled his head down and
slapped his head off
his head went off the ground he went out
he went out it was cut open his head i
think that seems a little bit out of
character for you i think that you
strike me as more of a
uh put him in a like like choke him out
and then lay him down nice and soft
typically that that would i don't but i
don't once once it goes to throwing
punches i i don't do that i i one had to
do that one time in college and got
kicked in the face while i was doing it
like never again so i once once a bunch
of people are throwing punches i i i try
to keep my hands free so i guess i gotta
snap and that's quick okay
i'm gonna get them off it keeps them
quick it gets it over and it's it's
quick
um yeah i don't know
hawaii or sandwiches san luis obispo you
went to slow okay
i say i lived there for 20 years holds
up
my whole fight career yeah so but yeah
but it i mean people ask about that i
had a guy i got
an extra cr maybe maybe he's still
assuming asked me if i was mad at him
and i'm like
no like it was a bar fight it happened
it happens it happens i mean it's or
whatever like
for what like
it was just you know i think pontius
asked about that or told me to ask about
that because pontius is from san luis
obispo oh wow so i think uh
it's like a local legend yeah i i
imagine so yeah we uh did a show in san
luis obispo not long ago and and uh of
course you're part of my show with the
cauliflower ear bit and uh you know when
i when i brought up your name i said the
pride of san luis obispo chuck liddell
and and you got love you always get a
lot of love every every time i do a show
i say your name man it's always a huge
cheer yeah and then the second part of
the bit when you're bleeding and you
like caught the blood everybody's like
dude how sweet you try to catch your
blood you know yeah you're like we got
blood
we're bleeding
well that was a big problem
it's getting it's getting that injury on
your ear without the blood right because
you have it
once it once it pops it doesn't
it doesn't stay there you need it to
blow up
yeah yeah
they said that my buddy was draining his
kids here like his eight-year-old
training his car fired fire i was
getting the blood out does an
eight-year-old get cauliflower here it
happens all the time wrestling right now
yeah wow i didn't know eight-year-olds
wrestled
when did you get pregnant was pretty
good when did you get cauliflower here
my mine slowly grew i never never blew
up like mine just slowly grew over time
i mean i got a little bit inside my ear
blowing up and it was so small i never
did anything about it and it was like in
my junior and in high school and then
i just grew through
college and then then wrestling now
junior i have to fight fighting
afterwards i was doing jiu jitsu and
stuff and
when you get it are you like [ __ ] yeah
um i i did not want to have it like like
some of my friends like this not really
but yeah it's a bad honor for a lot of
guys for sure i did i was
i'm still upset that i wasn't able to
get it
so you were you were already a
professional fighter you're still
working at the bar
um yeah at the beginning now right away
i mean i'll be honest like i look back
before um dana lorenzo came in i mean a
home run in that sport was 50 grand a
fight you know like it was like yeah you
know that's the main event that's a man
this is your main event or you know or
you're maybe maybe a little more than
that for some like a few of the guys but
from the majority of people that that
was a home run so when did you get in
the ufc
ufc 17 in 1998
okay and then dana and the fertitos came
in in 2000 2000 2001 now yeah so what
would like tank abbott get for a fight
when
the original one that i don't know i
remember actually i've never asked now
you said that like a fighter and you
can't even point to those early days
my first one i got i was on an alternate
for a tournament and i got a thousand
dollars to show up and if i if i i won
my my alternate match and someone got
hurt and i got into the finals i would
get ten thousand for second place
and it was a four-man tournament so i if
i got in i would have been in the finals
so you fight more than once in a night
twice if i fought twice i would have a
chance to win 20 grand total
so that was and in those early days
before dana and the fertittas like they
they're paying you a thousand bucks and
they're losing money right like it was
just uh yeah i think they i think they
they were they kept their expenses down
there probably but there was no one you
know you go to some of the i think that
first fight
i mean there's probably 2 000 people
there you know in louisiana
they fly they fly you in the day
of wands and think of me one time like
oh he's having a hard time making weight
i'm like what do you mean i just got off
the airplane
i started i actually wanted one time
like i started cutting weight on my
connect i'm like can i only always have
you on a connection to go you go middle
of nowhere but but we i started on my
connections like i put the cause like i
was landing after way as it started
so
i started i put my plastics on and the
sweats on top of them and started
running around and things so think about
i'm in a seat next year
flying coach obviously back then and and
you're like sitting there i'm sitting in
a seat next to you
like dripping sweat like i got okay i
think everything got a plastic suit i'm
right my eyes and i sweat bad something
i'm still sitting actually sweating
you're like
how do i buy this seat like how do i get
stuck with this guy next to me
i'm dripping everywhere they don't know
that no one has no idea i am i've been
i've never fought right never had never
been on tv before like why is this
weirdo
dressed in a wow and then back then a
bat and a
garbage bag and a freaking uh
sweats like and back then they were like
what are you doing this for you like oh
i'm going to go fight in the cage or
somebody they're like what the [ __ ] this
is yeah yeah
yeah back then i like i spent a lot of
time promoting people and ex promoting
the sport and trying to figure trying to
explain to people what the sport was but
man do you do you have to train for that
like you just get off the barstool and
just go
that was a normal question yeah yeah
that was like and it wasn't like they
weren't trying to be dicks they were
just like man do you have to train for
that you just just get up and get off
the part and god's one of those get mad
at somebody go go fight like
i guess you could do that but yeah we do
train a little bit out here
could you ever at that time like foresee
how big the ufc has gotten now i always
thought it would be get this big i just
thought it would take a lot longer to
get there and i think that that what
what happened was like really what the
big thing was our trojan horse dan was
first hosting a live fight on tv was was
a reality show yeah and that reality
show crazy is what really prove it
because
we got no because it was really hard to
break into uh people like like younger
people were understanding that or
understand the sport like breaking into
like through some of these companies and
getting in some of these executives that
guides the top like
that's that's
that's not good stuff
no one wants to see that but when we got
like it's like when those
fighters started going and they started
doing the show
the ratings that they got
were like wait a minute people are
watching this
yeah and then and then that fight i mean
you could ask for a better like uh was
it forced griffin was the first
foreigner was that first you know final
main event or first uh like like five a
fight for uh for that show and it was
like first live fight on tv you know
it's like
we couldn't ask for a better fight it
means like a goddess type you know like
guys going out and just they were and
they you know they were doing
mixed martial arts stuff that it wasn't
just like a striking or
too much wrestling there was a mix
everything so yeah it was such a great
fight for it you know it'd be that
brilliant when people ask me did you
think jackass would blow up and become
as big as it was
like i always say
i i understood that it would be popular
i just didn't think it would be allowed
on tv to become popular you know that
was like the
i just figured like how are you gonna
show the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that we do like
like what we do isn't allowed on tv
right and uh the kind of the same thing
with the ufc is that the the problem
wasn't whether it would be popular
enough to become as big as it is it just
would they [ __ ] show it you know and
and that's been a little bit of an
uphill battle and
like what what do you think broke down
the barriers
i just i mean it was just
you know it's like anything else ratings
ratings
if you get you get enough
once they were able to get and show how
many people really wanted to watch this
like oh
okay
well now dana's talking about getting on
cbs not abc and he's already had one on
abc so it's they've already had one
they've got another one coming up
and that was the one who's trying to get
hamza and colby on
i feel like you also got to give joe
rogan a lot of credit because like for
someone like me who's like not really
following the fc but i hear him talk
about it and the art of it and like the
intricacies of it it kind of makes me
look at it more as like not just some
violent crazy thing but yeah
i mean he's a make smarter strongest in
his own
yeah jiu jitsu guy uh did kickboxing he
was kickboxing guy i mean didn't he
start out in taekwondo i think and then
taekwondo went out a little bit and then
he
was an instructor for taekwondo yeah
i mean yeah i would like to see him in
the the ufc hall of fame i mean there's
got to be a spot for joe rogan in there
it's i mean absolutely and uh it's a
really good point that joe rogan
did so much for the sport
um you know what's up what's also
interesting too for all of like the
stigma of it and people think it's just
so violent and you can't do that and but
there's a lot more deaths in boxing than
there are in uh mma
yeah i mean well that comes with a head
trauma i mean there's only like there's
only so many things in boxing there's
the two different sports i i get
irritated when people start comparing
this and that striking and
it's different striking
you can't stand in a boxing stance and
strike and fight mma it's not possible
like like you stand a boxing stance
you're not gonna last long
um it's too easy to take you down and
it's too easy to kick you in the legs
like it you can't hearing the last of
the kickboxing match like i tell people
you take a guy in a boxing stance
and he's got one round to knock me out
in a boxing i if in a kickboxing because
i'm like if i can kick his leg by the
end of the end of the first round he's
not gonna be put enough weight on that
front foot knocking me out yeah he's
like
and so um
yeah it's different but like for boxing
a lot of it isn't there's so much um
there's a lot lot more head and trauma i
mean if you think about it there's so
many other ways to do things if there's
a wrestling and there's right right
there's ways to get away from it and
also they're not getting lost
you're not getting eight counts
you know it's not you're not getting uh
eight counts again so getting you guys
getting dropped multiple times in a
round right right now you get dropped
you flash knocked down a guy jumps on
you right it's over yeah you know that's
true you know you know you're not
getting knocked down
right
you know three or four times in a fight
yeah it was the the uzman fight in the
colby covington fight like the amount of
punches those took like a boxer would
take those every time they fight that
amount
that happens you know and that and that
happens with training too like they're
taking more shots in training right um
because like when it comes down to it
like you've got so many things to train
and only so much time
yeah so in a week you know there's only
so much time in a week there's only some
time you can realize you have to
you know budget your time to what
they're working on they're working on
wrestling working on jiu jitsu they're
working on their striking and mixing it
together they're whatever they're all
their strengths and conditioning all
that stuff you're trying to do all these
things so
you you can't spar as much you can't get
hit in the head as much because you're
not just not it's just there isn't time
yeah yeah
so you were like
the first real like
breakout star of the ufc right like
let's say gladiator i remember like i i
wasn't you know in like the early 2000s
i wasn't at all
a uh
like ufc fan you know i had tried to
watch it in the 90s and just found it
too boring because they had like uh
choke out or something with them it was
just it was just like grappling and the
rounds weren't there was just one one
long round so the grappling exchanges
just made it boring for me because that
round never ended
and uh so i wasn't really paying
attention but i remember
hearing your name a lot
yeah well i mean i mean for me a lot of
it was white right place at the right
time and but it's like i said when
you're giving you know everyone's all
you got lucky you got this opportunity
that atom between
but you still have to perform yeah
if you get as lucky as you want if you
get something if you don't do a good job
there you're not going to get it they
see him about actors all the time oh he
has lucky break at this yeah well yeah
but if he wasn't you know how how much
time did he take to get there doing what
was he doing and then how did he do when
he got that break because if he if he
got that part and sucked
he wouldn't we would never heard of him
right and in your line of work you get
your ass kicked you know it does not
matter
yeah if you go out if i got this big
break i go out there and i get knocked
out it's over yeah
yeah luck is when preparation meets
opportunity there it is thanks that's
true it's very true do you have a
favorite fight yeah something that you
think back to like i'm so glad that's in
the books
favorite fight huh well i certainly have
a least favorite fight the one i am
currently losing to donuts and all the
other garbage that i'm piling in my face
all day
man my diet has turned into absolute
crap and the only thing saving me is
athletic greens what's that well it's a
delicious convenient
comprehensive nutrition supplement which
i use every day man it fills in the gaps
the humongous gaps in my diet and it's
got
75 different vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens it's great for your gut
health it helps with your brain it
really improves your cognitive abilities
telling you this stuff is magic i use it
all the time and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
then they're going to give you an entire
year's worth of vitamin d which boosts
your immunity and overall health plus
five free travel packets with your daily
nutrition and you get all that if it's
your first order so get over to
athleticgreens.com
stevo and fill in the gaps in your diet
now let's talk about favorite fights
if you have to
put a gun to my head and pick one i mean
i'd probably be beating randy the first
time yeah i beat him um this is after
the ultimate fighter it was like you
know so
there's a week after we just won the
show i just won the show it was pretty
everything's all hyped up it was
probably it was the first
first fight i actually got my
pay-per-view bonus too so because we
actually hit enough big enough numbers
and we went by a lot
so it was um
and and i event and i avenged the loss
you know i was avenging a loss and i
that i i i
got back and i got to win by knockout i
mean it was a knockout
and close second of that was being ready
the second time because i i flew i felt
like i proved it wasn't a fluke
oh that's a flu keep you beat about yeah
because he lost first time for the
second time when i knocked him on the
first round and
this proof wasn't a fluke we wouldn't
did it again
do you have a ritual a pre-fight ritual
that you always do every fight or is it
varied do you want not people talking to
you do you eat a certain thing do you
not jerk off for five days beforehand
i'm very fascinated by like the the
ritual that that one that that one no
that that was never mine that was never
my understanding
ah
yeah i was as limited i was supposed to
be limited to
what i did before right before but no
didn't didn't didn't listen to that very
well
um
no but uh no i i i was that i i was at
my always i was really good with my diet
and meal prep i had meal preps like you
know i had to get i got my weight down i
got my weight down before the fight
i re like by the time by the end of my
career i was like
always knew what i was going to be 2 13
when i woke up she was about 2 13
13 and a half when i woke up to cut
weight it take me you know i easy cut
and then i just kind of cruised to make
the 205. um and you know and i i just
kind of relax man my thing is like for
me my my fight week
i always enjoyed fight week because my
training base the last year sparring on
saturday the week before the fight was
my last that's on my last day of
training and i was done like after that
i'm relaxed i'm good i just got the game
plans right we're ready with everything
and i just go enjoy the time like i hang
out with my friends we do abort we warm
up a little bit we didn't do much all
week training wise
and which is nice and then you know you
got to do your interviews and do all
that stuff go around and do that stuff
but thank you for running i mean i good
for all my friends i you know i
you know i guess walking out walking
from the hotel over to the arena i
always did i was always singing i'd
always sing sang
whatever had on on my thing which people
couldn't laugh because i go back and
forth from like country to like dmx to
slayer to
like what is wrong with this kid
actually yeah what's he like um
but uh
and then i just just go out and fight
man i enjoyed it like it was one of
those things i
i feel like that was my reward for all
the work i put in yeah it was a walk out
there so crazy to think of enjoying
fighting so stoked like justin gates
like i never sleep better than fight
week and i'm like i wouldn't sleep at
all you know just that anticipation or
yeah i don't know that's really weird
one of the things is off the top but
like there's a new way they do weigh-ins
now they know how they do the weigh-ins
at like eight or nine and then do like a
right fake weigh-in at like three or
four or whatever for the fans
i'm like oh really what is even the
point like i'm like okay if you want to
get us up at eight and nine tell the
fans we'll be there they'll be there at
eight and nine yeah that's when you want
to do the weigh-ins let's just get it
done like what don't bring me back it
don't let me bring you back for this
stupid thing number one number two
for me it really sucks because i i go to
sleep all my whole fight
prep i go sleep about two two three in
the morning
because i fight at nine o'clock at night
so nine thirty nine nine nine three at
night so i want my butt i don't want my
body getting ready to shut like if you
normally go go to sleep every day
at 10 o'clock
your body's shutting down
putting chemicals out it's ready to shut
down you know 8 39 you know it's ready
to go to bed
i i i got i get up about 10 30 i go to
sleep about
about 2 30. so that's that was kind of
my daily schedule and i usually took a
nap in the afternoon after training
um but i don't i don't know if i would
have really liked having to get up
like i would i'd actually have to have
to cut weight before i went to bed
probably because i wouldn't want to get
up at five
to cut weight for
longer it gives you longer to rehydrate
though i was longer to rehydrate but but
i did i was that was an issue for me
right i didn't because because i only i
didn't i started cutting my water that
morning so i only cut water from for
like it's been like like you're doing
like you're going to do a regular
workout today right and just waiting a
couple extra hours to drink water it's
you're not gonna get that dehydrated you
know
i lose 10 pounds i lose 10 pounds of
water but like
but the weight have to hold it off for
two or three hours it's not a big deal
right now now once you start holding
that overnight
i don't like holding it over that's one
of the reasons i do it that way i don't
like doing it overnight like i don't
like start i wouldn't i like going to
bed
deprived of water
what do you think about this
if uh if they decided
that
like at the little check-in station
where they they check your gloves and
they put the vaseline on your face and
stuff like like right before you get in
the octagon for the actual fight what do
you think if they weighed you at that
point so that you knew
stepping into the octagon precisely what
that person weighed i would be
fascinated to know how much how much
weight they put back on i think that
that'd be actually kind of cool for for
fans or like even even even just in the
in the locker room before they come out
anytime because you don't really give or
take a a few sips of water i mean if
they just when they came in and checked
their weight and just see what their
weight is the next day yeah but if they
were i mean they're already standing
there for like
you could see some of these differences
like especially some of these little
guys man i i'm impressed i'm still
impressed when they make that weight
like right
you know when a little guy loses like 20
pounds i'm like dude how did you lose 20
pounds you know
i don't know i've done like 19 and a
half before there was a day of weigh-in
so i made it but uh it was a
timing change so that's the guy who
doesn't mind doing it at eight and nine
in the morning
oh yeah yeah
as soon as i get it off please let me
step on a scale so but you you
you weigh in at 205
and then what are you
by the time
i was about 2 15 probably by the time
you got into the ring yeah you gained 10
pounds i gained it back out in like a
day that's why i walk around yeah yeah
because you just lost i lost it and they
put it back on crazy but um i'm sorry
then what's the point of the weigh-in if
you guys wait when you fight anyway
that's a good question well the point is
that there's only everyone everyone made
a certain goal weight like you don't
have to so we don't have to walk around
we have a base everyone makes it to a
base point the day before that's an
agreement like i said so i don't care if
you put on i don't get to put on 34
pounds if you cut so i had to cut 34
pounds to get there i know that took it
out of you so if you're you're 34 pound
heavier than me you know but you you had
to cut all that you had to cut all that
water make that weight
you're going to pay for it tomorrow so
you're paying for it right like so so it
does level the playing field yeah it
levels the playing field because it's
like a it's like for different people
like it's a
it's a like it's like deciding what
weight to stay at what weight to go down
to or if you go down a weight or stay up
weight right and it comes down to like
what what's the best where where am i
the best where am i i got the best
strength weight ratio like i where am i
the strongest for that for for my what
my body body type my weight my size yeah
you know and and it's just that's it's a
basic choice for people like everybody
makes it different like some people like
a lot of guys like some people don't
like to cut like i like to keep getting
now i get to i i just like to get to
where i'm about between 2 15 and 3 2 13
before i cut
now a lot of guys don't want to do that
like a lot of guys like to keep their
weight around 220 and cut down from
there they're more comfortable cutting
15 pounds that's what makes them that
makes what makes them feel strongest and
feels best so that's right and that
works for me too like i don't care as
long as you as long as you made that
weight we're fair you know it's fair
okay i could i could have kept my weight
up at 220 if i wanted to sure and cut
the same amount of weight and been
running bigger too but i didn't want to
because that i i would it's like if i
went everyone asked me if i went heavy
when if i went up to heavyweight
i still would have fought it like 2 20 2
18. i wouldn't i i
my body wouldn't when i carried it would
it would that would it would take a
while i would
maybe my third or fourth fight down the
road if i went heavy started going
heavyweight i would have started getting
bigger yeah but at that time like if i
decided to just go up for one fight
i would have been 218 because that's
where i was most comfortable fighting
right like if because i'd done anything
kickboxing before i was oh i'm gonna
fight heavyweight so i might as well
just be 225. i felt like a slug i
started pushing my punches
you got tired real fast there's a little
more weight to carry around so it makes
sense
do people do cocaine for
for a weight cuts or i guess they're
going to drug test you for the fight
yeah
pride they [ __ ] do whatever that
seems like a strange way to wake up but
i guess you could i wonder like if uh
if anybody is about to weigh in and
they're not to make weight have you ever
heard of anybody just [ __ ] donating a
pint of blood just to get that last
pound off that i have not heard i don't
i don't think that would be a good idea
you want that blood unless you're gonna
put it back in after yeah
put it back in afterwards
armstrong [ __ ] weight cutting [ __ ]
dude
yeah we're onto something now
that's insane and thanks for clarifying
that about the weight cut because i was
always like what the [ __ ] is the point
but that makes total sense what you're
saying yeah i mean and every everybody
when you when you agree to wait and if
you make the way that's why i hate when
these guys show up like eight pounds
over ten pounds overall yeah right you
show up eight ten pounds over you didn't
try
don't tell me yeah don't i don't i mean
i i don't i i just got on the scale made
weight if you if you were having that
kind of a problem making weight call me
up
let's call talk to me hey
um hi bro if you want to fight i'm i
can't i can only make uh you know
210 i'm not gonna make it let's do a
catch weight okay call let's go dana
we'll just do a catch weight okay not
love catch wait he doesn't but but i
mean if
it's between that and the fight you know
okay right right but if you because if
he's not gonna even try i don't wanna
try i don't wanna i don't
have to make way i don't wanna i don't
wanna make weight and then have him come
in at two ten two come over him weighing
it at two fifteen i weigh in at two or
five it's like that's not cool what
happens when that happens does the fight
still happen if they they ask that you
have to accept it if you want to and
those guys will negotiate
and then they give you you know
but i don't know what the you get a
percentage of that first oh okay okay
they'll renegotiate your contract right
down to the wire and let's say okay this
guy's not making weight but we're gonna
give you 20 percent of his purse well i
think that i think that's almost
automatic to 20 of his person
if he knocks you out you're getting 20
of what he'll make
correct okay all right yeah i think a
lot of i don't know you probably offered
a lot of different things depending on
sure too like you know like if it's a
guy trying to make it in the ufc you say
okay we'll give you we'll give you a if
you lose we'll bring it back anyway
we're not going to cut you for losing
since you gave up the weight right right
they'll make negotiations you know they
won't make the fight don't
all come down to it you want to fight
yeah i mean i've accepted i i've
accepted a couple guys didn't make
weight before back in the day but i'm
like yeah
that was close enough that's right guys
they're like is that okay like this
before there was commission oh wow okay
before hey
yeah he's [ __ ] like yeah yeah i look
at him he's trying he's good he's not
yeah he doesn't look he's not like huge
every year right the statistics really
show that people who miss weight and
come in heavier
win a lot like the the
like
your chances of winning coming in
heavier are greater
right so you're sacrificing twenty
thirty percent but you're probably gonna
win when you agree
when you agreed to fight a guy who
missed weight you are
like deliberately consciously taking
like uh a disadvantage in the fight
definitely right and so as such you
should get
uh financially compensated for sure i
agree
it's only fair it's like fighting with
steroids maybe not really but like
i mean you have a little bit of extra
weight behind you it kind of helps the
the cause yeah there are different
reasons
a lot of guys or maybe there's guys that
shouldn't be at that weight i think
they're too big for that weight you know
that they walk around right walk around
too big for that weight who's your
favorite who's your favorite fighter to
watch these days like of the young guys
coming up
oh man well that not young guys yet
there's still glo glover takes sarah's
still out there so yeah okay sure
is glover to share the champ still right
yeah he's ranked like top top five yeah
he's one of these one of my guys he's
training with me nice
he's uh he's a good dude man i really
like him and how old is he now he'd be
jan blehovich for the title does he
still have the title
he's guys
again um
uh shanghai uh june right yeah he fights
yeah that's [ __ ] scary man but do i
love watching all these old guys
uh
kill it you know like the old guys are
doing pretty [ __ ] well these days
like andre arlovsky with all the
victories and glover to share as the
champ and
[ __ ] uh
who else is that like uh like
alexi olenick just had a victory he's
[ __ ] 44 years old wow awesome yeah it
was his 77th pro fight he's 44 years old
it's crazy and he [ __ ] like was in
deep trouble and he [ __ ] switched
around and and that was great wow i
don't miss a fight chuck i'm a [ __ ]
that's awesome i'm i'm gnarly do you
watch them all
no
i i still love fights i still watch them
but i just don't i'm out of kids and
yeah it's hard to start to get the time
to watch all of them it's to feel good
that whenever you're at the
pay-per-views and you're at most of them
that like hearing the crowd roar when
they show you on the screen yeah it's
it's so cool yeah that's so cool to have
for sure that's fun i mean it's crazy
because like
like that that's just like
longevity man you have enduring
[ __ ] legacy man that's why i say
legend
well thank you i appreciate it uh you
know yeah
and so i remember when we were in peru
it was so crazy we were in this food
tent and you said like oh something or
other you know like we were talking
about representation you're like oh well
man i never wanted an agent because i'm
not going to let them take 10 of my my
[ __ ] fight purse you know and
especially if i come back and i said
like wait wait hold on a second did you
just say come back
and uh and then i remember like i had
you on camera like
uh and and you said i'm thinking about
fighting again and i was like have you
told that to anybody and you said no and
i'm like oh my god like the what this
camera i'm holding is so [ __ ]
valuable
[Music]
yeah that was that
it was i mean i was getting it was good
to go back go out of my own way um
but you know probably not that was not
the best option at the time i i needed
another neck surgery at that time so
mm-hmm
and actually i went down to
i actually went down to um columbia
got for the fireball accelerator yeah
and they they like took they i said well
you know i got some net i got it from my
shop went down for my shoulders it was
amazing i did it it worked amazing for
my shoulders but i i got my knee checked
but i had like uh i i just i did it was
just worn to the bone so it wasn't
but um and i i wanted my neck and then
so they did an mri down there so before
they do something on your neck that one
didn't mri i said yeah um
are you having problems with the balance
of coordination i'm like no i'm fine
i'm like
uh like oh well can you i think when you
get back you should go go see your
doctor about that that way you're not
gonna have your neck looked at
said oh all right and i'm like so
didn't worry about it when i got back
for about a month and a half and i'm
like oh
what's up
um
you you're having problems with the
balance of coordination chuck like what
do you mean no i'm not
yeah we should give you a check so i
want to get him right so
get the mri go ahead and talk to the
doctor get that come out and he goes you
know um
so he said so you're having problems
with the bounce girl what the hell is
wrong with people like why are you keep
saying this
i'm like oh really i'm fine i just
fought like i'm all right i mean i'm
good he's like really do me a favor
go stand in the side of the room walk to
me he'll tell
i try to walk you like like
watch him now close your eyes
try to do it i could
take one step like
wait wait hold on wait hold on let me
try this again try doing it he's like
okay yeah now now stick your hands out
stand on one foot put your arms out
touch your nose all right now close your
eyes
close my eyes i fell over i'm like wow
he's like yeah you're uh you're out so
you're
you're you're asleep you're your brother
forever is warm through it so it's
tapping your spine and it's
and so you're you're you're balancing
yourself with your eyes
your body's by so great like adjust your
brains yeah you know i wasn't getting
getting that right signals from from my
from anywhere else so my brain i was
using my eyes to balance for balance
it's crazy
like they're looking at like scientific
evidence that there's a problem but
chuck doesn't believe it
yeah yeah yeah then he's like yeah okay
okay i'm gonna move this guy out we'll
have you in surgery on tuesday i'm like
wait whoa time out what do you mean
tuesday
when was all this
um
um there's after that last fight you had
yeah after the last fight i had no idea
buy or accelerate to go down there and
get my shoulders and i was like it was
like about six months after last fight
and i went down there and uh but it was
like you know i went and it was funny
because i i'm like man what wait
why
why is uh why why do we have to do it
today like like this is not like i have
a whole cool like i'm trying to except i
gotta do another neck surgery and he's
like um
so well
look man
it's not a big deal it's just but if you
if we
if we wait if we wait there's a chance
if you get if you're getting a car
accident and you got a bad car accident
right now you you might it might you
might not walk again
and i don't want to be the reason you
got got like that was because i put you
off a month and after your surgery yeah
i got an opening right here and we're
going to do it on tuesday wow what's
that from is that from just years of
wrestling and fighting wearing terror
just wrestling and fighting i mean it
was just like because it was just worn
to the bone so it's just all just going
you kind of have that too right i've got
degenerative disc disease in my neck
yeah it's uh is that the same thing i'm
i'm not sure i i'm not sure i know my
mine's pretty like that though basically
they kind of explain the different
different solutions and i just basically
i'm sure chuck had it a little bit worse
is your is it better now if you close
your eyes
oh yeah i i was better why i was
honestly it was almost better walking
out yeah
walking out walking out the next day
when i woke up and
got up from and even even with your eyes
open did it feel like a different or was
it only when your eyes were closed like
oh i can stand up yeah only my eyes are
closed
but everyone said i was that that day i
was walking different again because
they're saying
my wife paid more attention to me than i
do so she's like yeah you were walking
you were walking different for a long
time for a while interesting is that the
ufc doctors doing all that or is that
just your own private doctors yeah uh
well i've got great i've sag insurance
yeah that's really good yeah so that uh
that last fight with with tito the one
that when we were in peru you told me
you were thinking about
like it was it was tough man and i know
that like the world responded to it and
uh
you know like
they they viewed it as sort of sort of a
a bummer
and i from my perspective
i uh
i thought well [ __ ] you know like here's
chuck he's a fighter he [ __ ] misses
it like it's in him like it's just like
i i just felt like
you know i i understand i understood why
you wanted to do it and i thought it was
[ __ ] great that you went for it yeah
and as i mean i have no regrets i mean
obviously i wish i was healthier and i
wish i you know i wish i performed
better but other than that hey i went
out and did my thing i like you know
it's what it is it runs something lose
something is i mean i i mean i i didn't
do any i didn't do anything i went out
and did the best i could i mean dude
as far as your legacy goes i mean it
doesn't [ __ ] change [ __ ] about the
fact that you're the [ __ ] ice man
chuck liddell dude right yeah i don't i
don't feel that at all and you're uh
you're chucking tito 30 for 30 was
fantastic
oh yeah that was awesome it really was
they did a really good job with that um
having it uh
you know getting it you know for getting
a lot of issues and a lot of a lot of
history and a lot of stuff i thought
they covered it pretty well yeah dave
for sure
and if your relationship with dana is
just great huh yeah we're still we're
still absolutely have a good
relationship with dana but you know you
know we were friends we we
i mean
he was my manager before this oh wow
yeah before he decided he was starting
to buy it they decided to buy it and
you know we didn't we don't always agree
on everything but that you know that you
don't always have to by the way guys
people you don't have to always agree
with your friends yeah right
yeah this it's okay to have friends that
think different than you do yeah
it's actually it makes life interesting
i don't know it's a controversial
statement
yeah
yeah like when you first stopped
fighting the like dana really took care
of you huh like yeah oh yeah for sure
the um and the funny thing like
um when i when i first when i first came
like i don't know why i think he i think
he forgets the story how it worked
because he planned on coming to me and
telling me to quit
like when we had a dinner meeting and we
we walked in and he said he said okay
you know what i said you know i'm really
retired i just don't want to i can't
give me a minute give me a little bit of
time to he said yeah man thank you i was
coming in here to tell you to quit i
wanted to create he was gonna he said i
was only i'll release you if you i'm not
going to fight you anymore because i
wasn't going to fight anymore i would
release you to fight anywhere you want
but
but i'm not i i can't do it anymore
you're done you're not you're not able
to
and and i
said i came in right away that's that's
what i said no i'm i'm ready to attack
it yeah those last handful of fights
which were tough man like well yeah
i mean
the last one i think i knocked myself
out really with that headbutt but but
still it you know it's one of those
things i i went like
i'm rich a great fighter and a tough guy
and i but
um i i thought you know he should be
able to knock me out like that and i
could
i should be able to take a punch better
than that and if i can't then
it's time to retire yeah
and so so he uh
employed you
right yeah and then i worked for work
for the usc for until well
you bought it
and then uh
i mean a year year after um
yeah yeah i mean they kept me on for
about a year and then right they got rid
of me i mean it is what it is i mean i
get it i mean a new company and and um
well right i mean if they're gonna
and i i wasn't i wasn't actually really
doing much
outside of having a uh my
you know you know i had i just got
married had my kids and i you know that
was like they they offered you if you
want to move out to vegas i'm like man
you know i'm
i'm okay
i mean i think that the way dana
describes it he was paying you to not
fight
right
that's great yeah he was uh and it was
like
yeah and i mean he said you know i had
to cut like you know come back three or
four shut up when they offered coming
for three or four shows a year you know
yeah
um and i was like and and so i just just
went to whenever i went up i went a lot
more than three or four but not what
they offered them i i like going to
fight so i love it i'm
yeah
every time i go to the apex like uh
forest griffin's just on site yeah yeah
i love that guy too yeah he's a good
dude that's it i think that's killer man
that uh
you know
for all the way people describe dana and
how he does business and stuff like i
think that it's it's really telling the
way he looked out for you you know the
way he took care of you
yeah
and uh to talk to like
rhonda about how much she loves dan you
know like
dana's relationships i think speak to
what kind of guy he is oh yeah that is a
good dude man i like dana we always have
it i mean no one's hey man he's
he's uh
he speaks his mind yeah i don't know i
don't like i said i don't always agree
with him but i i'm okay with people
speaking their mind i like it
you're not wondering whether he doesn't
like you or not for sure
you know why you're not wondering you're
not wondering is data mad at me like i
was just telling people about me like if
you if you're gonna ask someone if i'm
mad at you i'm not just saying that yeah
if
if you're doing something that makes me
mad i will let you know yeah
i mean i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not
aggressive by the way but i'm very
straightforward like hey don't be an
[ __ ] it could be an [ __ ] you know
i will let you know if you have to ask
someone or guess if i if i
don't like you or if i'm mad at you
uh you're probably safe to say i'm not
yeah
it's good can people like you ask my
wife hey man
chucks uh he's not really texting me
back is he is she mad at me but she's
like
he gets 800 texts a day like he's like
hey if
if if you send him at uh about if you
send me like a an ending like hey hey
look at this cool thing i did i mean i
might not get around to oh cool yeah i
looked at looked at it went okay cool
that's cool but if you need a response i
probably didn't respond yeah yeah but if
i did respond and you think it's short
like i mean short um if i respond i like
you
anybody if i'm texting if you're texting
me and i actually respond i like you
yeah because i if i don't um i won't
even bother to respond sure do you have
anything coming up
um
you know i just i've been doing a lot of
little things you know i've been been
working on uh doing that no chuck's
giving thing
doing like kind of a show we haven't
really i'm not sure what we're gonna do
with it but we're having a lot of fun
yeah yeah you stay busy going out and
doing i do a lot of fishing trips to
doing some hunting some uh
a lot of stuff with uh some with some
military guys
e3 ranch we go out there and do some
always have some fun with those guys
crazy guys yeah that's cool those guys
are nuts man they can shoot
oh my bad
i'm trying to remember it like i said
like uh
like before we get done
trying to remember the uh
you had some crazy like drugs and
private jets and like
like
maybe it was a private conversation
maybe it's a private jet no drugs yeah
something like that
i'm uh
if you can like color in like what it
was like going from being like like
working in the bar
to becoming this [ __ ] mainstream like
icon of the ufc kind of a weird way to
explain that so
it's a funny story
um
so i just won the the beat randy won the
title after ultimate fight
i was out visiting with the um
with a ford in
in
tampa
i was out visiting
and dana calls me and said hey you want
to go on vacation with me in the renzo
then and frank or whatever and i'm like
sure okay well for a week okay we're
gonna fly out here so so i get on
so i get on the plane i get on southwest
i put on southwest go back and i get on
there and i'm sitting there and i got a
window seat and this small jewel in the
aisle
and then no no one in my seat next to me
i'm like okay perfect
and um
last minute just got this guy probably
six six maybe 3 30
probably
comes on i'm like oh man
please pass please walk by
somewhere he walked walks by oh
comes back
um there's no other seats
ask a girl hey do you mind just me you
know moving in the middle so i could cuz
i don't fit in the middle he's like
she's like oh i get claustrophobic he's
like looks at me like
oh my god
so five hours like that right
to vegas so good face i picked up at the
airport in a car
and they drive me to the private hangar
where i get on a g4
with three other people and fly to
ibiza
where where we go over to the yacht
which has 80 which is
200 and a couple of the ounces or 200
over 200 feet
and have 88-foot tenders
and i mean
we were there for about a week i mean it
was
absolutely bananas
and and that they give you an idea like
i it was a it was that was such a wild
trip there like i mean stuff we did i
probably can't get into but um but like
it was it was so much fun and that's
when i had a we actually flew into
straight from there went to um england
to do a
tour promoting uh
ufc
straight from ibiza that not probably
the best idea but i get me land and i
got these two girls calling me up to go
out
i'm like
and anyone that knows me this was big i
went
uh i can't do it
i'm not gonna like why won't we just
come over
i'm like
no no no i i need to sleep right now i
need to sorry and i mean from like i was
so glad i did it because the next day i
didn't we knew we had a radio tour the
next day but i didn't know we were going
for like 14 hours
like i was like driving all over the
place did you get a raincheck
it was a smart move i was just doing the
the
well one of the times just made the
right and had to make the right decision
right oh man wow but yeah
but it's great but that's i mean i went
from like i'm i went from a kid i've
never been on a yacht
you know now
that was your first experience
i've ever been on is like so be like oh
man my buddy's got like a 50 a 54 or
he's got a 65 footer but oh cool like
okay yeah i've been on tender that was
88 feet okay cool you're like i'm about
to like i i at first i didn't know i
didn't know that
that's that's really not like a
like a 80 foot
yacht it's a nice shot yeah that's not
cheap yeah
yeah that's a very nice boat
you know you know you know you have no
no perspective really because i've never
remembered much of a uh you know but i'm
yeah i was a
blue collar kid you know let's just see
all right hey that's not what i'm used
to like but it was it was pretty crazy
but it was a pretty a pretty crazy trip
said the neck surgery like we had we had
a strip club out there
and then you know and i was like one of
the few scenes right but you know
and they they were um there's some guys
videotaping
right i'm like hey it's a security i
mean it's videotaping us like why what
that's not cool like
not that for me i just didn't think that
you know anybody else wanted a big
videotape
uh and i know i mean so security goes oh
he comes back over always demands i
don't care if he's a manager i don't
videotape us you know i just come from
being a normal kid like
yeah
yeah yeah
and i'm like i'm like
um and then and then go over and so
i'm like i'm gonna go over and get i'm
gonna go
i'm gonna grab it from the guy and then
i go oh hold chuck relax so they went
over and they they offered the guy money
for like they got i guess they have to i
didn't know they did this they told dan
told me after because i was like i mean
i was still
cough up being you know
i was going to come back and i'm like
dude let me go back there and take it
like i would hey i would have just taken
that phone for for 500 bucks give me the
500 bucks i would have just taken the
camera home
he beat the tape he said you can't take
the tape out and gave the camera back
and paid him 500. uh but but again
because he paid him money and he wasn't
gonna sell his other look man
i see that gorilla over there
he uh pointed me he's all um if you
don't send me this name to me he's going
to come get it
and there's nothing i can do about it
nowhere
so no that was
not a strip club but it was funny
wow
it was i mean it was upset but
[Music]
yeah yeah that's good
so so uh you told me the bio accelerator
which is the stem cell
operation which i went to it's in
columbia it's great awesome i mean i
like i was having problems putting my
bag up over the over the yeah i'm gonna
play on the plane like with
this motion hurt wow bad right and that
was i mean i fixed you that and that
really it really did
like a
phenomenal job on that wow so uh and the
next surgery helped through balance yeah
yeah my knee i got my i did my partial
knee replacement that that works great
see the nice thing about that was when i
did that like so okay finally i broke
down i'm gonna get it it was my actually
sunday like he's coming
we were playing soccer and i was limping
chasing him around playing soccer and my
second like dad you don't have to play
i'm like
what do you mean like
i didn't want me to limping around i'm
like oh
son i'm fine that's fine we could be
good so i'm like all right what do i got
to do to fix this i could go
say a partial knee replacement i said
okay okay so
now once i get that what can i do
and the guy the guy said well it's not
what can you do it's what should you do
you can do whatever you want and i'm
like really he's like yeah if he beat
your body like you have for the last
20 years you're gonna you'll be back in
here in 10 years i said 10 years perfect
yeah that was the first time i got that
reaction but
like oh i know what shouldn't i do he's
like well i don't want to do any long
distance running i'm like damn it like
oh yeah no long distance running
yeah yeah yeah
sold yeah
you could yeah i just swear
like no hiking is fine they just didn't
want me doing that like running pounding
long distance yeah exactly
that was the worst thing
but everything else was within
moderation that's fine i'm like oh
perfect so i'm banned from doing the
thing i hate the most yeah and
everything else is good perfect yeah how
do you how do you stay in shape now i
mean you're pretty jacked and you got i
i lift and i i still hit the bag so it
admits i'm still trying sometimes i
haven't been wrestling enough but i
still like to do a little more jujitsu
i'm starting to learn more ghee stuff i
i was having fun with that for a little
bit my buddy was helping me just got got
uh
yeah i've got kind of had a i've written
a surgery so it's like uh
i got some weird hit and i needed to get
it fixed so it's been a while but but
yeah but i'm starting just playing
around i still like doing jiu jitsu i
like
jiu jitsu and uh and like striking like
just moving around sparring and doing
stuff is is kind of one of those things
that allows me to get centered like like
a knot yeah and just kind of like not
think about other things because usually
my mind's raising about a million things
at once and that helps me kind of calm
down
right
so you can play soccer with your kid now
oh yeah now now i can run after him and
goof around and then he doesn't get sad
that i'm limping it's great that's
crucial
yeah wow i was like man
it's worse did i look that bad
i did look pretty bad
yeah well that's good man and
um and what's no chucks given
i you know it's honestly just me doing
stuff uh you know they offer me to go do
crazy stuff and i go do it you know
who's that um the guys from uh they do
with me uh
guys from uh leviathan
i think about hey hey you wanna go uh
you know go shoot you know go go hunting
or you wanna go out fishing or go do
some wanna go do drive uh for side by
side you wanna go do
go the dunes whatever whatever okay cool
let's try it you're like i don't give a
chuck
dude that's epic man we're [ __ ] right
on chuck is there anything that we can
uh drive traffic to for you uh you know
just all my social media stuff like that
chocolate i mean uh it's a chuckling i
think it's on all of them i think but uh
yeah
good man to get on there the instagram
is your favorite yeah
that's what i'm on the most i guess yeah
yeah cool
do that i do twitter
but yeah so i'm trying to check the
noah.com back up but i have to get that
back so we'll talk about all right maybe
we can we can help with that [ __ ]
my brother wanted me letting you know
that you hit like a [ __ ]
yeah that's epic man what dude i love
you chuck man thank
[Applause]
[ __ ] yeah all right
good deal man
yeah dude how about chuck liddell man i
[ __ ] love that guy
and how about this palm tree
get a look at that
that's what you get right here in
rutland vermont and i cannot verify the
truth of what i'm about to say but i was
told that rutland vermont has a
population of 16 000 people
uh over 800 of which will be in this
theater tonight i don't know what
percentage that represents
what would that be p
i haven't how many people that's like
[ __ ] almost 20 of the population of
the goddamn town's coming to the show
tonight and it's me and preston lacey
yeah dude
so [ __ ] love you guys man thank you
for sticking around for another episode
of the wild ride podcast and i'd love it
if you give some love to uh to chuck
liddell let him know uh how great it was
you know [ __ ]
tag him in a post
yeah whatever thanks man love you guys
you